all right now that we've seen this in
action let's go ahead and use it
ourselves
what I'd like you to do is create a new
canvas Dom object inside a new div Dom
object that is then put inside the body
element and I do this we're going to
have to grab the body element by its ID
of body we're gonna have to create a new
element using document create element
both for the div and for the canvas then
we'd like to set their IDs the div will
set it to game content and for the
canvas will set it to game canvas
finally we'll have to append both of
those the canvas to the div and then the
div to the body you'll have to use
document dot get element by ID document
dot create element the append child
method of Dom objects and the ID
property to do all of this